So, vielleicht kommen die ganzen auch nicht mehr. Das ist auch möglich. Wolken und Niederschlag, Rom und Weiß, wahrscheinlich eh schon einiges.
So, einfach mal fortfahren. Also, ich habe schon mal Windi aufgerufen. Und zwar das sogenannte Programm, weil mit dem ist es dann doch gerade am morgigen Tag sehr gut sichtbar, wann bzw. in welcher Höhe vermutlich Wolken vorhanden sind.
Auch da habe ich wieder das Icon D2 gewählt für morgen. Wenn man da für Sonntag schauen möchte, dann empfiehlt sich da das europäische oder das größere Icon mit 13 Kilometer Wolken.
Auf jeden Fall, wenn man da für den morgigen Tag, wenn man hier sehr hohe Wolken hat, also Night Level 300, 300 Hektar Wolken, das sind 9 Kilometer Höhe, das sind Kirchen, die da reinkommen oder drinnen sind, dann rutscht das Ganze etwas.
Nach unten auf ca. 5000 Meter gibt es da Bewölkung inklusive ab 15 Uhr leichten Niederschlag. Und am Freitag sieht man dann schon den ganzen Tag mit Kirchen und hohen Wolken und Niederschlag kombiniert schlecht sein wird.
Wenn wir uns das auf Niederparaport anschauen, dann sieht das für den morgigen Tag ziemlich ähnlich aus.
Allerdings haben wir jetzt ein bisschen...
Dann steht da noch Niederschlag voraus, also hier ab 17 Uhr leichten Niederschlag, sehr aktive Bewölkung, aber da oben kann die Bewölkung zu den passenden Höhen noch gehen.
Also mittlere Bewölkung hier und rutscht dann runter, sehr effiziente Bewölkung ab 18 Uhr mit deutlichem Niederschlag.
Das sieht man hier eigentlich auch.
Da ist es ein bisschen klebter zu sehen.
Im Hintergrund ist es meist grauer, aber man sieht, dass da eine Bewölkung drinnen ist.
Das ist auch sehr gut sichtbar.
Im Wetter ist es aus meiner Sicht ein bisschen unübersichtlicher, aber man sieht undeutlich, dass da eine Bewölkung drinnen ist.
Ab 11 Uhr sieht man zum Beispiel der Grab schon in den Wolken drinnen.
Das sieht man da gut an dem Fassierten.
Also die Berggipfel.
Die Berggipfel sind da größtenteils in den Wolken drinnen, schon ab 11 Uhr.
Wenn wir dann auf 17 Uhr, weil der Niederschlag ist im Generell prognostiziert, die haben wir auf 17 Uhr ein bisschen raus, da zeigt der jetzt bei uns noch nicht richtig Niederschlag an.
Möglicherweise kommt sowas aus der Wolke raus, aber die größeren Stellen sind da noch nicht ganz vorhanden.
Das ist ein bisschen unterstetter.
Da sieht es dann schon deutlicher aus.
Also ab 18 Uhr in der Regel sind sie sich eigentlich alle einig, dass da dann der erste Niederschlag mit reinkommt.
Wenn wir dann noch hier rein sitzen beim SRV, da kann man dann die Bewölkung da anschauen.
Das ist halt auch aus meiner Sicht nicht ganz so übersichtlich gemäht.
Wenn man jetzt mal nur die Tiefe bewölkt.
Die Bewölkung anschauen, sieht das für morgen 13 Uhr ein bisschen anders aus.
Da kann man dann schon nochmal ein bisschen eher sehen.
Man muss halt wissen, wo wir sind.
Und jetzt sind wir da bei diesem kleinen Knick.
Und dann kann man auch vielleicht für seine Region schon ein bisschen mehr ausmachen.
Gerade da unten mit der Zeitachse dann ein bisschen weiter nach hinten fliegen.
Und man sieht die tiefe Bewölkung gerade an den Gipfeln wird halt deutlich stärker.
Aber...
Persönlich finde, was das angeht, also bis jetzt auf dem Netto Schweiz, wo habe ich das da?
Also das Elb auf dem Hemd sind diese Winde als solches mit der Darstellung sehr gut, übersichtlich und glücklich gewesen.
Wie gesagt, man muss dann halt für seine Region schauen, wie oft es hinkommt.
Es ist bei den Wolkenprognosen mal sehr, sehr gut passend und mal halt auch ziemlich daneben.
Daher ist es so ein bisschen mit Vorsicht zu betrachten.
Also gerade im Ausland bin ich sehr schlecht gefahren.
Hier in der Schweiz passt es häufiger gut.
Aber im Ausland ist es jetzt nicht so häufig so gut gewesen, dass ich sagen muss, ja, da kann man sehr oft aufsetzen.
Den Niederschlag haben wir da eigentlich auch schon mit drin.
Den Niederschlag haben wir aber eben dann auch noch die Möglichkeit da bei Meteo Schweiz.
Weitere Übersicht, Kartenquellen, das finde ich halt schon noch eine sehr gute Variante.
Man kann da noch ein bisschen rein scrollen und dann in der Zeitachse da noch nach vorne gehen.
Das geht natürlich nicht allzu weit, aber gehen wir mal da auf 15, das ist die Uhr.
Da sieht man, dass die größeren Teile noch weiter wechseln.
Da will ich jetzt mal ein bisschen nachsehen.
Ja, das macht gut.
Die sagen jetzt fast, das ist bei uns noch ein bisschen.
Ja, das ist dann auch bei uns.
Weil da fast im Uhrland, da geht es dann nicht direkt bei uns.
Aber so am 7. bei uns, eine Stunde früher oder später, ganz genau würde ich da nicht drauf gehen.
Aber uns sind wir alle einig, dass am späten Abend dann...
...dann der Niederschlag reinkommt und dass am Vormittag bis am späten Nachmittag bei uns eigentlich noch der Niederschlag fern bleibt.
Das bringt am Föhn ja da uns noch das Ganze ein bisschen vom Leitbild, wie man dann auch hier oder hier überreicht.
Ja, eigentlich erst gegen späten Abend dann, wenn der Föhn so richtig zusammenkommt.
Dass der Föhn dann reinkommt, dass dann der Niederschlag beginnt.
Also so kann man sich eigentlich relativ gut vorbereiten.
Mit dazu noch das R-Active-App nehmen, wo eben die, wo habe ich die, die Bodenblockkarten,
nicht nur die Prognose wie hier, Entschuldigung,
das ist nur die vorherberechnete allgemeine Lage.
Wenn er es dann tut, ja.
Also nicht nur die vorherberechnete allgemeine Lage, sondern eben auch der Ist-Zustand vom Kreuz- und Wetter-Dienst.
Den Link dazu vom Kreuz- und Wetter-Dienst habe ich euch reingetan.
Mit dem könnt ihr dann auch in der Analyse ein bisschen nach vorne gehen und schauen, was da vorhanden ist.
Und wenn wir das jetzt am Morgen anschauen,
am Morgen,
am Morgen.
Am Sonntag könnte man ja mal schauen,
wir haben zwar den Notdern,
aber es ist auch interesshalber,
mal schauen,
wie da die Prognosen aussehen.
Umявierung
Europäische
geht bis am Sonntag
mal da
für einen Wind auf
3000 Metern herz und wir sehen,
dass da
48 kmh Nordost
gemeldet ist,
war es jetzt nicht unbedingt
eine gute Richtung.
Es gibt vor allem hier eine ordentliche
Stärke.
Auf 2000 Metern wird das deutlich
weniger sein, aber die Frage ist
halt trotzdem, ich gehe davon aus,
dass man da trotzdem
vielleicht sogar 15 kmh
Nord
links haben am Startplatz
und dann wird das
allein schon vom Starten her
nicht mehr so sein.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob Meteor
Apo, Sonntag ist
mit drinnen, wenn wir da
anschauen, deckt eigentlich
da auch wieder so ein bisschen das
Bild, vielleicht
von der Stärke her hier auch sicher noch mal
10 kmh.
Da doch oft
daneben liegen, aber
immer noch vielleicht 30 kmh
auf 2500 Metern
Nordost, schlechte Richtung.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus,
dass das am Sonntag auch noch
nicht so vielversprechend
aussieht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man
so gut sehen kann für am Sonntag.
Ich glaube,
der Anzeig, also 2000 ist
eh sehr stark erwähnt.
Das finde ich auch cool, dass
die Fläche 2500
hat. Das lädt
bei mir jetzt einfach nicht so gut.
Aber
vermutlich wird eben
genau das eintreten,
verbreiteten
30 kmh von hinten.
Das könnte ich mir jetzt noch vorstellen,
dass das bei uns eher der Fall ist.
30 kmh von hinten
und nicht von hinten.
Also aus jetziger Sicht
mit allein dann
innen beiden Verbündchen abgeglichen
kann man eigentlich sagen,
dass das am Sonntag eher schwierig
wird.
Der Wind auf 2000 Meter,
da bin ich ja in der
Flügel-Hobby jetzt im Winter und Sommer.
Das ist mir besser, weil im Winter
hat das jetzt in der Vergangenheit nicht so gut
gestungen. Und darum
nehme ich eigentlich die Referenz
im Moment immer 3.
Und hier bei Berni auch noch cool
die 200.000 Meter.
Und ich gehe davon aus,
dass das in etwa hinkommt.
8 bis 13 kmh
Meterjahr. Das wird
vermutlich am
Startplatz ankommen.
Und dann wird es halt schwierig,
allein von zu starten.
Wenn man da auf die Verkaufszone
sieht man, dass man
im Winter nicht, dass es da
auch nochmal ein bisschen besser kanalisiert.
Der Gat durchzieht den Nordost.
Also von dem her,
jetzt reingeht am Sonntag
vermutlich vom Wind her
der limitierende Faktor.
Wenn wir auf die
Vorhersage
Bodendruckkarte vom deutschen
Wetterdienst kommen,
dann haben wir am Sonntag
Luftdruck, bestimmendes Wetter, Biesenlage.
Das geht anhand
von den Isobaren hier.
Mit der Verkrümmung da haben wir
eine Biesenlage.
Windprognosen
jetzt, wo wir haben,
definitiv.
Ist natürlich nicht immer so.
Aber wenn wir jetzt da die Isobare
entlang gehen, dann sehen wir, dass wir da
eher Ost-Nord-Auswind haben.
Und das weckt sich
definitiv in die drei Prognosen.
Also das ist
ziemlich auch
ein Grund,
was grundsätzlich, denke ich,
vor der Bewölkung hier ein guter Tag sein könnte.
Da muss man natürlich bei
Winden immer den Hochnebel
in Betrachtung ziehen.
Und da
kann man eben hier bei der
Heuchel der Diagramme noch auf
den Hochnebel gehen und sagen,
was der so für eine Obergrenze hat.
Und der wird am Sonntag
voraussichtlich
an die 1800 Meter
gehen. Das ist sehr hoch.
Das ist vermutlich so ein
Tag, wo der Hochnebel sogar bis zu
uns hinterzieht, hintergedrückt
wird mit der starken
Wiese.
Könnte das jetzt für den Sonntag
auch für uns ein
sehr limitierender Fass nur sein.
Also kann sein, dass es
über 1800 Meter
eben sehr sonnig ist
und darunter hängt man
dann im Hochnebel fest.
Ich denke, wenn man sich so
versucht, ein bisschen vorzubereiten
mit den verschiedenen Apps,
schafft dann auch
Vergleich. Das ist immer ganz wichtig
am Tag selber. Wie war
die Prognose? Hat sie
gestimmt? Ich habe jetzt eben die
Erfahrung gemacht, dass gewisse
einfach gern zu viel anzeigen,
zu viel, vor allem zu viel
Wind angeben oder halt
einfach auch eher auf der pessimistischen
Seite sind. Aber
schlussendlich ist das ja für einen
Flieger besser, als wenn zu gut
gerechnet, zu positiv gerechnet wird,
zu optimistisch gedacht wird.
Und klar, steht man vielleicht
des Öfteren am Startplatz und
muss dann tatsächlich entscheiden,
ob das noch gut oder schlecht ist.
Von dem her, da müsst ihr eigentlich eure
eigene Erfahrung aufbauen.
Was stimmt auch für euren Ort,
wo ihr dann vielleicht auch gerade seid.
Einfach bedenken im Ausland
oder als Tipp mitnehmen,
funktioniert Meta-Karabu sehr,
sehr gut. Wir haben
in Albanien, machen sich eigentlich
alle ein, dass wir aus normalen
Hüttendecke vorhanden
sein wird. Windy, ich habe
noch andere Karten angeschaut,
die das prognostiziert haben.
Börner hat auch in Albanien
komplette Bewölkung,
8 Achtel angezeigt.
Nur Meteo Parabor hat uns
eine Wolkenbasis angegeben,
2000 Meter, 200.000 Meter
und schlussendlich haben wir
fast gar keine Wolke gehabt.
Da müsst ihr dann wirklich schauen, was ist
für euch an dem Ort
das bessere Mittel
und dann vielleicht halt mit zwei
Maximum-3-Apps arbeiten.
Ich stelle euch
noch den
Gutschaum-Code.
Wer möchte, der kann bei Börner
eben das Abo lösen.
Er kriegt 10 Franken
gutgeschrieben auf das jeweilige Abo.
Wie gesagt, ihr könnt
bei Börner
extrem viel Infos
herausnehmen.
Es sind auch
sehr lässig, mal abgesehen vom
Wetter, dass man beispielsweise
dann auch
aus dem Ausland viele
Informationen, die stark
in den Landesplätzen oder
in allen Systemen
noch erhält, finde ich
von der Darstellung her schon
wahnsinnig gut.
Finde ich nichts anderes, was
mit einem Blick
so zentral so viele Informationen
herausgibt.
Ich war am Anfang kein Fan
davon, bin aber mittlerweile
schon überzeugt,
dass das auch eine gute Sache ist,
und darum gibt es da die Möglichkeit,
eben auch mit dem Gutschaum-Code
10 Franken einzufahren,
wenn man das möchte.
Ich werde es nachher im Projekt
noch verlinken,
und wer das
nochmal nachfragen möchte,
oder auch speziell nochmal
Fragen hat, der kann
mich natürlich direkt anschreiben,
wenn er jetzt nicht ganz sicher
sei, woran er mal
gewisse Informationen abrufen könnte,
über das einzelne App.
Oder das Ganze
dann später
auf der Homepage unter dem
R-Active-Bereich nochmal nachschauen.
Da werde ich die Präsentation hochladen.
Ja, ich würde sagen,
das war es so von meiner Seite.
Habt ihr noch Fragen?
Das wäre eigentlich noch ganz cool,
falls jemand Fragen hat.
Oder ist etwas unklar gewesen,
zu schnell gewesen,
zu wenig Info gewesen?
Dürft ihr das jetzt gerne,
schreiben, oder Hand heben,
oder gerade Mikrofon an,
und die Fragen stellen?
Thomas, hast du eine Frage, glaube ich, oder?
Ja, du, eine Frage, und zwar,
wie tust du beim deutschen Wetterdienst
jetzt die potenzielle
Hochnebel-Obergrenze, wo hast du
das gefunden?
Also,
auch da schicke ich euch den Link.
Ja, super, perfekt.
Wunderbar.
Weil das ist noch gut zum Speichern.
Warte mal.
Das sind einfach Daten
vom deutschen Wetterdienst.
Gut, ja, noch andere Fragen?
Auch solche Sachen?
Natürlich willkommen.
Wenn da noch etwas unklar ist.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen,
ist eure Aufgabe ganz klar.
Morgen schauen.
Wie haben jetzt die Prognosen
gestimmt, wo wir da heute
angeschaut haben?
Ist es eingetroffen mit dem
starken Föhn? Ist es eingetroffen
mit dem Niederschlag am Abend
zwischen, sagen wir mal,
18, 19, 20 Uhr?
Das ist etwas, was ihr morgen
abgleichen müsst. Vielleicht einmal
schauen. Klar, unsere Station geht
jetzt nicht, aber die Grabmaschinenstation
auf zweieinhalbtausend Meter, die geht.
Da könnt ihr auch wissen, was ist da
für ein Wind. Das sind zweieinhalbtausend
Meter. Dann könnt ihr schauen, wenn das
so um die 20 bis 30
kmh Wind ist, dann ist
da auch die Prognose gut
eingetreten. Hat da eigentlich auch
gut gestimmt. Also das ist das, was
ihr morgen mal machen könnt. Und das empfehle
ich euch auch für die Zukunft,
auch vielleicht für Tage, wo nicht
fliegbar sind, dass ihr einfach schaut,
was habt ihr für eine Prognose
gemacht und was ist tatsächlich
eingetreten. Weil nur so könnt
ihr euch verbessern und lernen und
merken, hey, das ist sehr gut,
das ist nicht so gut gewesen.
Für unsere Region
ist eine Sache,
wo ich festgestellt
habe, schaffen viele noch mit,
Meteo Blue, aber
das hat jetzt bei uns in unserer
Region fast nie gestimmt.
Also drum müsst
ihr da eure eigene Erfahrung sammeln,
wenn ihr mit dem arbeitet.
Ich persönlich bin kein Fan.
Auch da muss man dann ein bisschen zahlen,
wenn man gewisse Anwendungen nutzen
möchte. Und drum habe ich mich
auf die drei, die ich euch da vorgestellt
habe, interessiert. Super.
Ja, wenn da jetzt doch
keine Fragen mehr sind, dann
bedanke ich mich und ich hoffe,
dass das euch ein bisschen geholfen hat
für die Vorbereitung, für die
Prognose. Es ist nicht einfach.
Ihr müsst euch da reinarbeiten
und halt
Erfahrung sammeln. Das ist wichtig.
Danke vielmals für deine Zeit.
Danke auch. Schönen Abend
noch.
Ciao.
Tschüss.